[Music]
the pipeline that carries gas into our
Valley is now fixed after last week's
leak it was discovered last Thursday and
by Friday many drivers were filling up
tanks some in a panic Mary Jane bellies
alive at a gas station off Flamingo and
Paradise where drivers are worried about
another problem now Mary Jane
oh yes that's
out of fuel now drivers are worried
about high gas costs and if those prices
will go down
a gas pipeline leak impacting fuel
shipment from California to Las Vegas
led many drivers to Panic by Fuel over
the weekend now drivers are on the hunt
for cheaper gas prices
according to John trainer with AAA the
average gas price in Nevada is more than
four dollars last week we were at four
dollars and three cents today we're 414.
so we saw an 11 Cent jump from last week
to today
um yesterday we were 413 so if you could
jump the penny overnight now that is
completely the opposite what we're
seeing in most parts of the country
where we're starting to see prices
really ease up and prices dropped about
three cents
um over the weekend for much of the
other rest of the country so you could
see really One impact that Gastly had in
your wallet Governor Joe Lombardo
declared a state of emergency stating
Nevada's price gouging is strictly
prohibited during this time but drivers
are skeptical right now I have to pay
about four nine I think it's absolutely
insane and um I usually just try to fill
up maybe once or twice a week but
usually I'll try to have my parents help
me out because it's been terrible it's
almost doubled the good news maintenance
on the pipeline finished Saturday with
operations back on track demand should
settle as people aren't buying now that
the pipeline is back up and operational
at the same time Supply is still going
to be there so we'll see those prices
drop pretty quickly
now each gas station does set their own
prices and AAA does recommend you shop
around GasBuddy shows costs where you
are not this gas station off of Paradise
and Flamingo gas is under four dollars
at about 393 per gallon reporting live
Mary June bellezza 8 News Now